[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys it's me Jenny
damn covering the faces of why potatoes
are making fat sick and others and why
you want to cut those cars off out of
your life look good and I've partnered
with McCain who are sponsoring this
video to tell you why that's really not
necessary
well I've been doing some extensive
research on dr. Google and I found out
that the key to a healthy life and a hot
bod is to get the hell away from the
potato have you heard of the term
everything in moderation debbie
moderations for the week it's all our
bucks if you want to get leave oh that
is a whole other video there Debbie
forget about it let's talk about why
those starchy potatoes have got to go
potatoes make you gain weight and expect
your blood Sugar's because a full car oh
oh gosh Debbie we talked about this
before carps do not make you fat and
cutting out carbs are not going to
necessarily make you skinny in fact your
brain needs carbs in order to function
optimally
and research has actually looked at low
vs. higher carb diets and found that low
carb diets are no more successful when
it comes to weight loss ditto for low
versus high glycemic index diet and this
is not really surprised me very much
considering the research also is shown
that guys in general don't work so
please just stop the car sphere right
there yes to speak to potatoes a large
meta-analysis found that there wasn't a
strong association between eating
potatoes and the risk of obesity
cardiovascular disease and diabetes so
my advice to do is to enjoy your
potatoes in moderation so I'm talking
about portion sizes of up about a cup
per serving pair it with some lean
protein like chicken beef or tofu and
lots of fibrous vegetables helps slow
the blood sugar response and keep you
satiated longer if you peel / - you lose
out on all the nutrients
stop being dramatic potatoes are an
excellent source of vitamin C they've
more potassium than a banana + b6 iron
magnesium and high quality carbohydrates
the only thing you're kind of missing
out on when you peel your potato is the
fiber and not by much we're talking
about 2 grams with appeal and 1 gram
without the peels it's not really a
make-or-break scenario if you can't get
me to peel sweet feels are good
the whiped isn't that oh god w here you
go again with a good food of bad food
mentality crap let me break it down for
you now compared side-by-side sweet
potatoes and white potatoes are not
actually all that different 400 grams
they both have around 90 calories plus
they both packs vitamin C potassium iron
and magnesium sweet potatoes have more
fiber and vitamin A while white potatoes
have more iron so it doesn't need to be
a leader or scenario here honestly you
can enjoy both of them in moderation
just depending on what you're craving
and how you're craving it so for example
I prefer to have my white potatoes as
french fries and I like my sweet potato
face so you do use frozen fries are
highly processed and they're made with
street additives preservatives a weird
ingredients you can't even pronounce you
might be surprised let's take a look at
this bag of McCain super fries so the
ingredients are just potatoes canola oil
sea salt sodium phosphate to retain
natural color and color and honestly if
the McCain process is super simple it's
just wash peel cut cooked and free so
what you see is what you get and
honestly it's all coming from the
goodness of the potato so some of the
trade off of a little processing means a
realistic creation of a scenario where
you can actually have a balanced meal so
it's cooking up some McCain super fries
means that you can catch Lisa have them
sitting down to a nice family meal I'm
all for it yeah with those frozen side
there's a little bit spree of fat
saturated fat and sodium that cause
heart disease
again don't jump to conclusions until
you get the facts a serving of McCain
super fries for instance are trans
fat-free
have just point three grams of saturated
fat per serving and only 4% of your
sodium needs for the day I also know
that McCain is working really hard to
reduce the sodium and fat in its
products without compromising flavor
taste or of course quality the other
nice thing when it comes to heart health
is that potatoes are loaded with
potassium and potassium actually works
in opposition of sodium so you promote a
healthier heart what the hell Abbi
you're literally saying is just binge on
french fries all day actually I'm saying
that if you enjoyed all foods including
potatoes in moderation there wouldn't be
a need to binge on anything and while I
would never tell you to cut out anything
indefinitely I can definitely say that
potatoes are both nutritious and
delicious choice well in that case
french fry diet starts today oh dear
well guys Debbie I hope I cleared up
some misinformation out there when it
comes to potatoes if you like this video
be sure to give it a thumbs up leave me
a comment below with some of your
favorite ways to enjoy potatoes
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen and for
more information on potatoes be sure to
check out Mackenzie a